speaking of people who have power over
your life and also don't deserve power
over your life there's a new book that
is coming out titled laptop from hell
hunter biden big tech and the dirty
secrets the president tried to hide by a
new york post columnist named miranda
devine she says while joe biden waged
war on white privilege from the white
house his own family was the living
embodiment of the worst of it joe has
always made sure the bidens lived a life
of unearned privilege and entitlements
under his beneficent patronage like
members of a hereditary aristocracy the
bidens would have access to the best
america can give the most prestigious
educational institutions internships
clerkship scholarships directorships and
government sinicares
decades ago the president decided that
hunter biden would act as the family's
cash cow says divine hunter who would
have preferred to be an artist or a
writer was assigned the role of paying
the bills for the rest of the family
through lucrative grace and favor jobs
and sweetheart deals facilitated by
joe's network of connections in delaware
and later throughout the world
in addition to records from his missing
laptop showing hunter held ten percent
of chinese business to deal
of a chinese business deal for the big
guy divine quotes an email hunter wrote
to his oldest starter naomi in 2019
quote i hope you can all do what i did
and pay for everything for this entire
family for 30 years it's really hard but
don't worry unlike pop i won't make you
give me half your salary hunter later
alleged allegedly complained to his aunt
who raised him after his mother's tragic
death that although joe biden co-signed
student loans for hunter and bowe he
expected hunter to pay off both loans
dad never paid one dime hunter wrote in
an email according to the book
devine says she found evidence that joe
biden benefited from hunter's deals in
multiple emails such as one concerning
jrb bills in another email detailed by
divine dated april 12 2018 hunter gets
locked out of one of his wells fargo
accounts because my dad has been using
most lines on this account which i've
threw the gracious offerings of eric
schwerin a close family advisor have
paid for the past 11 years when schwerin
writes about the amount of money in my
account his scare quotes imply its
contents belong to him in name only
so in other words the biden family has
been engaged in a grift in which they
used hunter as basically their cutout
for years and years and years and years
and these are the politicians that we
trust
they're all grifters
so many of them are grifters
on all sides of the aisle by the way
but the the
notion from media is that you ought to
again give them more and more and more
trust they're not disconnected from the
american public by the way speaking of
being disconnected from the american
public just want to know quickly be
booty judge who democrats are now
touting as a possible replacement for
kamala harris should joe biden go down
before 2024
p booty judge yesterday man of the
people pete booty judge from south bend
indiana who can afford to take two
months of paternity leave based on the
grave of physical
harms experienced by him and his spouse
during the birth of their child he
needed paternity leave for two months in
the middle of a supply chain crisis we
were all supposed to not notice
and um and now p booty judge has such
sympathy for the american people that he
says you shouldn't worry so much about
gas prices after all you can buy
electric vehicles electric vehicles by
the way are going for like 40 50 000 a
pop if you just families got that lying
around sure pete makes perfect sense
most of the physical infrastructure work
uh was contemplated in the bill that was
just signed but there is more envisioned
in the build back better law i'll give
you one example it contains incentives
to make it more affordable to buy an
electric vehicle up to a 12 500 discount
in effect for families thinking about
getting an ev families that once they
own that electric vehicle will never
have to worry about gas prices again
well i mean if you buy an electric
vehicle you'll never have to worry about
gas again sure you're driving a beat up
1997 honda civic and uh you're just
attempting to get to work and you're
making 45 000 a year but for that entire
salary and a little bit you could
probably get an electric vehicle
i mean sure you wouldn't be able to feed
your family this year but you could get
an electric vehicle according people to
judge
these are the folks you have elected
these are the folks you have decided to
put in charge of your life
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video